tatta your fame has been lovely to fans
that you very nice you go see yeah
you're very good David you're a big fan
but someone else in your family is also
very big fan yes
my mum's a big fan and we were in a
restaurant at the River Cafe about
probably about seven years ago my mama
drunk a bit too much and she suddenly
felt a bit ill and I led her outside to
the tables and you assassin one of the
tables and she's stopped dead and I had
to sort of drag her like you would a
donkey on a beach away we were so
excited to see you well how ill was she
otherwise you've got to be borrowed up
over dishes here tomorrow and let me see
if I can figure out who she is
hmm I can I can see her already she's
blushing she's smiley look at her look
at her Oh mother she's here you go love
come here darling I see you
with some welcome
all right he's a good mama boy you're
not proud of your lad down here and very
42 million books of this one of these
days he just might win enough
right
that's so kind of you she's a good mom
but it very hairy
notice respect firemen our was he a good
boy no come on
off the record was he a good boy
sometimes Oh
showing off now cuz you get Tom
we're now recording Toy Story 4 so we
were doing that it'll be out in 2018 as
a matter of fact so it takes a long time